[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ER I love you
I formed Bridgewater in 1975. when I
began all I wanted was meaningful work
and meaningful relationships I came
across Ray dalio in 1977 and we pursued
our dream I was part of the generation
of the very beginning
when we crashed
so for me seeing what my friend Ray and
all of the people had built in the small
part that I had a long long time ago
when Ray and I were just two young kids
very moving for me and we got to know
all these money managers and Ray started
asking the question he said
you know we're telling all these people
how to manage money why can't we do this
ourselves and one thing led to another
and you know our first client was the
World Bank in the mid-1980s and from
that point the rest was history
and can you imagine that the World Bank
give us five million dollars to manage
this is our ragtag group they give us
five million dollars to manage
when I started we had nothing we shared
a desk we shared a computer and we
shared a cardboard box as a filing
cabinet
we got a call from the U.S treasury to
come down to Washington and talk to them
about inflation index bonds we were five
minutes late and they had locked the
doors and Ray just walks up and starts
banging on the door for me this story
still resonates
um as a kind of analogy for how we had
to do things back then was sort of barge
our way into things we were turning the
string into a reality because we in fact
had everything we absolutely needed we
had a small group of people who had a
commitment and a passion just to do the
right thing when I got here there were
about 650 people so maybe a third of
what we have today you could see the old
Bridgewater was still a little bit there
it's kind of really growing from a small
company to a larger company what is to
me the most important part is the people
each thought represents a person who
worked at Bridgewater by year
everyone surrounds you here and they're
very involved in thinking about how
you're feeling that is supportive
um it is like my second family we have
all formed the community so this is what
Bridgewater looks to me you all have
relationships with each other that are
magical relationships I
found watching a family video
we love each other and we drive each
other crazy right
and we drive each other crazy because of
tough love I've been trying hard to take
in some of Ray's coaching and it can be
hard to understand so the drawings like
this big circles and and then he's like
I don't understand why you don't
understand I faced this and said I know
this guy loves me I know this is coming
from Deep care and I took everything
that I did and compared it to what was
described in the principles and I
started to see the gift that he was
really giving I used to walk on Wall
Street where people were not honest with
me and coming here like really changed
my life that was very shy very withdrawn
and being at Bridgewater I'm more
outspoken and I stand up for myself more
and I love that what is it like it's
it's humbling and it's rewarding and
it's painful
um but it's great we together as a
community have been successful 73
billion
give or take a few hundred million is
what we made for our clients we're the
number one firm out of 11 000 firms in
one of the most competitive Industries
in the world
so that brings us to today we Face
challenges together and our reality is
that I with the help of a lot of great
people have been able to build a
remarkable past but have failed to build
a sustainable future and so it's going
to require you all to be successful and
so I want to just read what I want for
you I want a community in which you
always have the right and obligation to
make sense of things a real functioning
idea meritocracy
I want to help you all struggle well and
evolve to get the most out of life but a
born for all else I want the great
Humanity that is Bridgewater
[Music]
for me it's a dream come true for other
people maybe it's what the future holds
meaningful work meaningful relationships
they feed each other it's the greatest
riches that one could have
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you